اشهر تاريخ
تم تداوله في محلين تاريخ بنشر نعم تاريخ
ابن بشر لا نجد فيه نصوص عاميه كثيره الا
يعني شذرات نادره يعني وهو كانه هو يصرح
انه يعني ان هذا اللسان الملحون او اللسان
العامه هل هذا سبب
تهميش هذه الماده العلميه او الماده
التاريخيه هي كانت ظاهره عامه عند
المؤرخين لانهم يرون الشعر هذا ان لا يرقى
الى مستوى انه يدور عندهم وهذه انا انظر
لها اسمح لي على النظاره هذه لانه اشباح
علماء
لان هذا ثقافه المجتمع اللي انت تحاصر
والعامه الناس همم هذا همم شعرهم فالمفترض
انك تتعامل معه كما يتعامل معه ابن خلدون
ابن خلدون تعامل معه في القرن الثامن
الهجري
ودافع عنه قال هذا هو الشعر الفصيح لم
يختلف عنه الا بالضوابط النحويه ولا
ينتقده الا لما يفت ده الملكه ملكه التذوق
الشعر
فيها من هذا السبب اهمل الشعر انا وجدت في
مخطوطات في مثلا في دول اخرى وثقت الشعر
العامه ويخص الجزيره العربيه واستفدت منه
طلعت منه شعار لم يكن معروفين هنا بس
واعطتني اضاءات معينه
وعكسه ابعاد معينه للحياه الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه في الجزيره العربيه في فترات
زمنيه طيب اخر سؤال عندي من خلال رحلتك
المدينه هذه
ومعايشتك العميقه للشعر الشعبي وتقليبك
لاوراقه ومعانيه
عندي سؤال بسيط
شعر شعر العامي في الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والعهد الباقي معروف الثانيه هلا نستفيد
من خلال خلجات الشعراء ومشاعرهم واحاسيسهم
ذلك الاحساس بفقدان الامن في الجزيره
العربيه وانهم يعني حينما يمدحون الدرعيه
او يمدحونا حاكمه حاكمه البلاد يا دحونا
ايضا في منجز الامن
خلال التوافق في هذا الشهر النصوص هذه
اللي فيها همم الاحتفاء نشاه الدوله
السعوديه الاولى في فرض الامن وهمم وتامين
الناس وشعرهم بالاستقرار
فكان متطلب اجتماعي تحقق لهم همم
الامام محمد بن سعود ومن بعد الائمه حتى
عهد قريبه الملك عبد العزيز اذا هو شعور
عام شعور عام عكسه الشعر جميعا النصوص
تقريبا لا تخلوا من الاشارات والتضامين
هذه هذه المعاني الساميه